video games have some pretty iconic
sound effects
[Music]
but I'd like to add one more to that
list that sound is instantly
recognizable if you've played any games
or watch any movies set during the
Second World War the most recent of
course being Call of Duty World War 2
the ping of the m1 garand has become a
sound synonymous with the world war 2
shooter genre just as the sound of Mario
picking up coins is linked to
platformers and the Metal Gear Solid
alert sound is married to the stealth
genre it's a sound you'll hear a lot in
the game and it's a sound that most
first-person-shooter players have been
conditioned to have a Pavlovian response
to not only is a very prominent in
gameplay but it's also used in the game
menus and was featured in the call of
duty marketing material leading up to
release but why is this weapon not only
been in hundreds of movies and games but
how does it make that bloody sound that
so many players love here's a brief
history lesson the m1 garand was the
standard US service rifle from 1936 to
1959 it fired a 3006 Springfield round
and was produced to numbers higher than
5.4 million during World War two the
weapon was so effective that General
George Patton called it the greatest
implement of battle ever devised the
weapon gave us infantryman a significant
advantage over the Axis powers who at
the time in which America had entered
the conflicts were largely using
bolt-action rifles like the German kr or
the Japanese arasaka the first game of
the m1 garand prominant appeared was
commandos behind enemy lines a 1998 RTS
game by pyro studios but the first time
a shooter fans would get to use the
weapon would be in 1999 for those of you
never played the first Medal of Honor on
the original PlayStation you took the
role of fictional lieutenant Jimmy
Patterson who through the game would be
recruited into the OSS as he completed
objectives and destroyed enemy access
positions here's a fun fact for you
Steven Spielberg actually helped get
Medal of Honor off the ground outlining
the idea after watching his son play
Goldeneye and combining it with his
interest in the Second World War
after Medal of Honor the weapon would
remain a mainstay in world war ii
first-person shooter games and by the
time the Call of Duty 3 was released in
2006 it already featured in 25 games
alongside dozens of movies and TV shows
many titles that use the garand
to the misconception that partially
expanded clips couldn't be ejected until
empty in Call of Duty three you'd have
to fire all eight rounds until you'd be
able to load another clip while back in
the real world you could reload a
partially empty clip the manual of arms
did call for the rifle to be fired until
empty the garand was fed by an end
blocked clip a solid piece of metal that
holds the rounds to be inserted as a
unit into the fixed magazine of the
weapon after the last round is fired the
clip is ejected from the weapon
resulting in the trademark the reload of
the m1 garand is probably its most well
known feature the iconic pinging of a
cartridge being ejected is always a
satisfying sound to hear after
exchanging fire with your virtual foes
when a new clip is inserted the bolt
would slam shut
which would sometimes catch an
infantryman's thumb if they weren't
quick enough resulting in an injury
known as m1 thumb or grantham during the
war reports rose the enemy forces were
used in the distinct sound of a clip
being objected to get the drop on them
and catch them reloading the report
started research into using plastics
instead of metal but nothing was ever
implemented although according to former
German soldiers the sound was mostly
inaudible over the sound of gunfire and
their tactics never change to take
advantage of the M Mons pinging sound as
it's more than likely that other squad
mates were able to keep firing while
their comrade reloads so if you've ever
wondered why the m1 garand made that
sound now you know I know this is a bit
of a different kind of video that you'd
usually see on GameSpot but I thought a
few shoots of fans would like some info
and how one of the coolest sounds and
games came to be if you'd like to see
video similar to this one leave us some
suggestions in the comments below and we
will do our best to accommodate and if
you want some more Call of Duty content
make sure you're head to gamespot.com
[Music]